one of the things i've
i've noticed i've been doing a lot
lately especially since school's been
out because i mean they basically
canceled school here
i'm in toronto for those of you guys
that don't know but um they cancel
school here
just the week after march break which is
around i think the second or third week
of march
and we don't know if things are going to
return to normal in september in the
school system or if they're going to
alternate days or if they're going to do
you know social distancing desk spacers
or dividers or what the hell is going to
happen but
we'll find out soon enough but i found
myself doing a lot of
correcting on social narratives just in
day-to-day life like standing on dots
what's happening in grocery stores
mass people's opinions of you people
driving in cars by themselves with masks
on i noticed in that video
you know you were talking about um you
know people riding these electric bikes
with mass on and not even pedaling
it's like i see the same thing because
i've been riding my bike i mean the gyms
are still closer they're actually going
to open on friday here thankfully
finally but i've been doing a lot of
cardio just to try to keep the
you know the conditioning up but you see
these people on these bike paths and
they're on these electric scooters and
bikes and
they're the ones that need to be
pedaling like they need to move their
body more like this
like this is the systematic weakening of
the human
male like the western male is becoming
pussified
because of things like this and i find
myself constantly correcting the social
narrative to my own child
to let her know what the truth and what
the reality of the marketplace really is
you know the world as it stands
you find yourself doing that with your
boys a lot oh you know
it's it's kind of i i've done everything
i can to keep my boys away from any kind
of social uh
you know conditioning as far as tv goes
i'm very
mindful of what they watch um you know
the school system the public school
system my kids in public school
unfortunately they're not going to be
able to go back this year and i've
always i've raised them up to say listen
guys
when your teacher taught t talks and
let's be honest
i said 90 plus 90 plus percent of all
teachers are female
um and they're being indoctrinated by a
lot of women in the school system and a
lot of their opinions and i tell them
all the time guys
you guys go to school listen to your
teacher when it comes to subject matter
when it comes to them teaching you math
um
historical facts but when they start
spewing their opinions what's a lot do
nowadays
i want you to pretend like she is the
teacher from charlie brown
i want to go in one ear out the other
and
that's up to us as parents to teach them
the way of the world for me when they
come home we have we have life lessons
you know we go out and we create in the
garage we build we
we're making swords and shields they're
making like apocalyptic type weapons
you know when the riots are going on we
went outside with one of my old wooden
baseball bats
hammering nails in it to have like a
little weapon for them i'm teaching them
how to shoot guns
um you know i'm teaching how to cook uh
barbecue we're doing
manly things we just got back from a
trip in utah cliff jumping out and
out in the lake and so we do a lot of
stuff that guys do
right and i
we don't have enough of that in today's
society we i have i'm lucky enough rich
to have a gym in my garage
so the gym shutdowns aren't that big
a big bigger deal to me i make it a
point when the kids aren't going to
school right now that
they go in the gym with me do a little
light workout push-up sit-ups
bodyweight squats they're only 11-9 so
we're not doing like heavy lifting or
nothing but they're in there working
and i take two hours out of the day when
we have to get out of this house
go somewhere whether it's on the beach
at a baseball field
play catch um go to the beach throw the
footballer on something
they have to be active a couple hours a
day and then after dinner at six o'clock
they have their free time
they want to play video games or what
have you but you as a parent we just
can't let our kids
sit around um because you're lazy and
don't want to deal with them giving them
technology and that's that's
i think that's what's failed a lot of
the people that are up to
out today these social justice warriors
they've been raised on all this
technology now they're growing up
and we're seeing the whirlwind of that
so i believe technology is a big problem
of what we're seeing in today's western
mail
you